[Music]
had to keep it up
yes we did cause we back at it again
[Music]
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
first of all I hand for my burnt orange
I'm wearing burnt orange I like the I
like the how you mix it up with the
colors usually in a black or brown yeah
a gray yeah yeah something boring
speaking of which I gotta make I gotta
kill something I said I'm uh my podcast
that told is not taking orders anymore
because we're so backed up which is true
we have so many orders
um at Toe Hold but but you just won't
get your product by Christmas yeah so
the people like oh we can't order it
anymore no you can you can replace them
after Christmas yes we got bags wallets
uh beanies flip-flops and you can order
whatever you want the the like the big
boy ones you can get the big boy ones
you're just not going to get them by
Christmas we had to shut down we got so
influxed by it so the problem it's a
great problem it sounds like it might be
time thousands thousands of orders
that's what we're talking about right
that's right in uh alcohol sales I was
getting on my Distributors the base of
Atlanta I was getting on them like why
are we not overseas are going on this
and this and then we talk to people that
are in the business like yeah that's not
how this works yeah like really no you
want to do like five big markets like
you know in Texas Tennessee California
um Arizona I think Denver and they're
like you want to just focus on those
because if you expand too fast we can't
fill the product it's I'm learning so
much it's like and also your your
Whiskey's quality yes and it takes a lot
and the same thing with like because I I
kept hounding AG about price 500 350
bucks but but he was like listen there
are 550 steps to go into these these
flip-flops we have a small team of
people who make them by hand if they are
not for everybody if you don't want them
it's okay but so we just the one thing I
noticed is that people you may have a
smaller customer base but we have more
than we can handle so if you keep
churning out [ __ ] quality like that
what we do is we get these customers
that obsess and they order more than one
more than two so it just depends on what
kind of business model I think quality
over instead of mass production that's
like with our whiskey it's a higher
price point so like that uh bourbon
Outfitters who's our only distributor
online
he sent us the numbers last week because
we're doing because I was like oh black
Friday's coming up what are we doing for
the discount he's like well we don't
discount tiger thick he's too high end
of a whiskey he's like have you ever
seen like pappies or these other yeah
you don't you don't use your own
discount I go we gotta do something
otherwise what's the narrative on the
Black Friday he goes Apple doesn't have
discounts yeah he was like we can do
five dollars off shipping no he's like
and I'll I'll eat that cause I'll take
five dollar shipping board a discount
and she said he called me up and he goes
he goes uh I think we're going to run a
special like oh what he goes one dollar
off it's like that's [ __ ] hilarious
because that's it you don't need it's
just a different animal yeah just a
different distance you know if you want
them but you learn the ropes you learn
the ropes did you learn there's so many
things when you actually look at numbers
running a business and you're like let's
offer a hundred dollars for flip-flops
he's like no that's not what they do not
what we do because then you're going in
the market with the big boys then you
compete with crops yeah and we don't
sell Crocs like my guy and bourbon
Outfitters he's like you're the number
one selling brand at this point price
point on on our site by far Nationwide
number one really I'd rather I go who
outsells as he told us and it's like
24.99 25.99 and he's like you're not in
the same category no that's good but I'd
rather sell something I I believe in
that I get behind like instead of
cheapening the product there's cheaper
ways to make it I mean I can't I
couldn't drink it or shill it out right
sure as hell can do that right yeah I
wear them all the time for a reason you
do wear them non-stop you run them on
stage I don't want to sell anything I
don't believe in no I don't well I don't
sell them on stage but I tell you what I
don't wear them I walk forever in these
yeah I walked uh five miles last night
yesterday I'd rather walk in these oh
Shins
Chin's looking good again thanks man
training
now living now are you excited for
Thanksgiving
uh I like Thanksgiving I like that it's
less effort
um my girl loves Christmas so Christmas
music is already playing and there's yup
trees up candles are burning and all
that stuff because you know usually it's
uh the day after Thanksgiving is the
traditional when you're supposed to put
the tree up yeah but apparently there's
some new hype where people are starting
up way early like micro put ours up two
weeks ago let's be honest if you and I
were gay and we lived together we
wouldn't have a treatment no we'd have a
treat really no I love it yeah we do Elf
on the Shelf you find it I lick your
butt and then we'd have our little would
we adopt kids or just have a bunch of
doggy dogs
um would we cat or dogs we'd be we'd be
dog guys we'd be birds speaking of dogs
gay bird guys [ __ ] big gay toucans
yeah and [ __ ] Hyacinth you ever seen
what a hyacinth bring up highest they're
so mean looking no we can't have that
they're mean no no the hyacinths are
sweethearts no we want the we want the
the pear the repeat everything you say
about the boss Hyacinth swallow the
gravy those they're huge and they're
[ __ ] gorgeous six thousand dollars
and they're such sweetie pie for my man
if you're my man I'm buying you two of
those dude what yeah you did not and you
go like this cover your eyes cover your
eyes and the bird just climbs on your
shoulder and then you know what I say I
go I didn't get you a present but I got
you this well and damn no no now take
some poppers pick a spot on the wall
because Daddy's going to town that's
what I said and the new birds are gonna
watch that's right now now we got a bird
watching no speaking of dogs
I didn't tell you this I decided to do a
best of and I uh there's a guy who's a
[ __ ] I think that stupid bird off the
screen yeah there's a five to twelve
thousand oh yeah oh yeah they're not
playing around
um they uh this guy Matt Ridler who is a
um who's a former Navy SEAL and starts
training dogs you know he rehabilitates
dogs with PTSD from the war and then he
he goes to Holland
and gets those special Dutch Shepherds
there's like you know Holland is where
they take it very seriously if you want
if you have a police dog a Dutch
Shepherd it's a whole different thing
malmos yeah it's kind of the same thing
but I guess the Dutch Freedom bigger
and uh he had a 67 pound dog
and I put on a bite suit
yeah and he had that dog he's trying to
get them views yeah yeah well Daddy no
Daddy wants a suit you know I'm obsessed
with that whole bite thing but but this
was an experience because I put the suit
on and he goes you're gonna try to Jack
the car and the woman who's the Handler
had the dog by a leash in the car
and uh he said just come up to the
window and I'm just like a little
nervous because I only have the suit on
my face is exposed did they give you any
warnings I don't throw the dog in the
car oh that [ __ ]
he's got but they they say put your
elbow in there now don't put your hand
whatever you put break your hand
whatever you put is he's gonna bite
right this is 67 pound dog yeah small
dog small
skinny
lean now the dog I'm walking towards him
and I'm just doing this I'm going look I
just want I want to get in the car I'm
doing I'm gonna get in the car yeah
because robbers do that you're right the
dog she's got the dog on the leash the
dog is looking the dog's not moving just
looking at me like that
just looking at and she this is in the
car she's in the car okay I'm walking
toward the car okay she's just the dog's
just going like this
she rolls the window down the dog is
still just looking at me and I go man
give me it like that
that [ __ ] crapped me so fast and
Bubba 67 pound dog
when it was biting on my arm and then I
had Nick whose arms are that big Nick
was like you got to get it off me he's
gonna shake it off shake it off
Shake It Off people don't understand
what a 67 pound Malinois when it gets
its back jaws and it's sinking its teeth
to the gum line in that suit and going
I was like do they say like don't like
try to gouge his eyes out rip his ears
so this guy so so Matt who was a Navy
SEAL for 12 years who's very familiar
with violence yes you know been through
all it and and worked with dogs all that
he goes he said people which you don't
understand is that when a dog like that
bites you and that's a 67 pound dog when
a dog like that bites you he's pulling
and tearing and he's fighting you to
kill you he's chewing you up he's not
gonna give up your body shows that
things happen to your body that you're
not you're not used to that you're not
in that situation ever the pain and the
and people cannot believe so you can see
it you can see it on YouTube you have a
guy on PCP or he's going crazy and he's
beating up 10 cops they let the dog
loose you can see the [ __ ] and what does
this guy do he goes it falls to the
ground he quits right away scary because
you don't understand that crushing they
can bite it's so powerful and he had a
suit thick uh it's a bite suit Bubba
it's not a bad one it's that thick okay
it's so heavy you're walking weighs 20
pounds on your body more I mean that's
what you're doing but check this out so
he he was working with a German Shepherd
that's lit yeah he was working with a
German Shepherd a big one
and it bit his arm and here's the thing
it bit through the suit and and
cut his skin no I mean ripped his skin
up he had a picture of his whole arm was
Savage that's how hard somebody it's
just a strange bite oh yeah they're not
giving up they're not letting go but
it's not it's not that they're they're
they're 70 pounds you can swing them
around it's the jaw strength and I
thought to myself that's a 67 pound dog
which made me not only afraid and Nick
was the same way nickos my elbow still
hurts because it grabbed his eyes I'm
sure because the pressure [ __ ] and he's
like that that still hurts yeah you guys
do this in Dallas in Dallas and I kind
of I was and it made me I I got a little
we all both got depressed why and
because because you realize how
vulnerable you are well you realize what
a dog can do well
the mountain lion was like Hey thank you
hey old [ __ ] that's what I'm saying I'm
starving that's what I'm saying you're
not doing anything nothing sir no that's
120 pounds 140 pound king of course
is well trained oh have to because
that's such a liability because that dog
will kill someone and not only that then
you think about a mountain lion then you
think about a wolf well think about the
thing about a bear dude I love when they
say fight a bear really it's gonna bite
me no we're gonna do you're gonna do
nothing you're gonna do nothing and
people don't realize what it can do to
you and then you've got and the hardest
biting animal is
Jaguar no but not bad it's not the
Jaguar hyena yes but no
gorillas actually have stronger bites I
believe oh my God but forget a gorilla
gorilla bites you oh well forget it with
those teeth I don't know why they have
some crocodile crocodile has the highest
bite for us American alligators and and
America and Nile crocodiles the American
alligator I have the high look at that
America Nile crocodile 5 000 America
yeah five thousand pounds per square
mile beats us though dude oh yeah it
crushes you well it's a dinosaur right
that's all there's dinos yeah so it
grabs you and we'll see you but I I just
realized there it is Jaguars have the
strongest bite force of all cats at 1500
PSI
but you don't even need that I mean if
that mountain lion gets a hold of you
it's games that match that's correct on
the trails remember I totally saw a
mountain like Bobcat I was terrified
yeah you know that thing that when
they're wild yeah with the claws yeah
it's not just the bite the the because
they they're gonna dig into well they
these [ __ ] apps you got a little
muffin top digging that Muffin Top
they're digging in your mouth they're
gonna get into that top well these are
your ass beats dum-dums these [ __ ]
eyes chained to a wall on Instagram I
don't know why it was on it and they
they let a pitbull after it and the lion
went the white line went like this I
mean the tiger went hey stop and then
the dog kept coming and the line went
hey really the tiger went grabbed them
and just bit him and killed him that was
that fast I was like Hey guys like what
do you expect
it was on Instagram it was gross you
don't want to post [ __ ] gross it was
on some website and I didn't expect to
see I saw someone around the dark web I
saw uh some crocodile had a giant like
anaconda in his mouth
but the there must have been a fight
because uh it was on must have been on a
Cayman that's a Cayman but the Anaconda
and him were fighting because you could
tell the the Anaconda wrapped around his
body but he lost the fight because he
was just cruising yeah like that time
saw that dead dude cruising he was
cruising with the anaconda in his mouth
oh boy you're like God dog
I would say a guy who's a 145 pounds who
comes at you and it's a real fight to
the death he gets he gets dealt with
pretty quickly oh yeah yeah yeah no I'm
bite him like uh if you're crazy you're
you're if you're if you're an intent on
killing the guy in your house oh you
have to you're you're yeah you're gonna
break his neck very quickly yeah all
right yeah like pretty quickly like it
might be like dog tiger yeah it'd be
cool
be sad huh my kids would be terrified
Daddy I know but you would do this you
do that thing you do or you go crazy no
it'd be like Weekend at Bernie's I'm
like no he's fine no he's fine fine look
at him
the best version Jimmy Burke tell us
about the [ __ ] guy he and his girl
having sex on the couch and a guy breaks
into the [ __ ] house boys I'm back
there in the living room guy runs just
breaks into the [ __ ] living room they
start fighting the guy's naked with a
hard on
she's hot as [ __ ] the wife calls my
husband's fighting a guy right now the
cops come and they get there and the
guy's got him and he's holding on to him
like that he let him go the guy was blue
he killed him oh damn he held on to it
yeah the cop goes don't worry about it
you're a hero nothing it was in Staten
Island Jesus he's like you know he died
he killed him he wouldn't let go they're
like let him go because I'm not [ __ ]
let him go I'm not letting him go I
don't know yeah I told us like that uh
suit we're getting dark it was like that
this kid was like nine or seven and it
was like in China his grandma kept him
with a stick because like one candy do
something like that she kept hitting
them and then he was fighting back and
got her a headlock she goes to her knees
and he just holds it kills Jesus Christ
he's just holding it in the his older
brother comes like what the hell are you
doing and he's like let go and let go
she was dead he literally held it for
like four minutes oh Jesus yeah not good
that's not fun to die that way I'll talk
to you right now that's the bomber no I
know what to do in a headlock sure sure
what you do nothing excuse me in a
headlock I know exactly what to do okay
I don't sit there like a [ __ ] what do
you do what am I gonna do step behind
you and [ __ ] sit you down on your
stupid ass yeah that's what I'm gonna do
and then you want to try that and see
how it goes no problem doing that okay
stand up you're gonna let me put you
know actual headlock daddy's gonna apply
pressure huh huh what you seem a little
hesitant now first of all what makes you
think you can get me in a headlock no
you just said I could get you that you
said I can do that because you can
coffee
and I go like this and this is the last
thing I go
I love your kids for you
you put me in a headlock
show us techniques for how to get out of
a headlock
I mean well how to get out well because
you don't know the technique wow I'm
here well hold on no see you're already
hand fights that's not really a headlock
right so daddy's gonna be here right and
then you're probably gonna the the best
thing to do is a tape down here yeah
yeah yeah you could run me four because
sometimes well no you go forward and
trip you can put the deer or I can run
you forward here because in order for me
to base out because then I'm one minute
yeah and now I'm here yeah now you're in
deep [ __ ] because what I do is I suplex
you I suplex you I don't understand
because that's where I do that now take
your drilling your kids
there it is again hand drag this is a
problem for you this is a two-on-one
here that's it guys that's a Russian
two-on-one because I'm gonna do this but
and then Bop
hey that see that little shimmy there
yeah
I'm good you're running forward
it's a bad idea to hold on to I I
sometimes you can step behind though and
sit him can't you no why would you pull
them on top of you no you don't want to
see it and then you can still have the
headlock if you run forward unless he's
just an idiot wants to hang under the
head which would be stupid he's gonna
have to base out so if I'm here like if
you have me in a headlock yeah I'm here
yeah I'm gonna pinch you and run up
see I don't want to run down here my
neck is on the chair I know
I know yeah okay
well you had my neck on that yeah but
that'd be the ground
are you good
and that's the lesson today I don't like
that you can pull myself for
Thanksgiving I don't like you pull my
hips in like that sorry Daddy I was
bracing I know but you have to base out
until I go in my head if you don't I'm
just gonna run you the map you're like
that yep
[ __ ] man don't get shopping you're
feeling a little frisky because you're
around that stupid dog you know I do
that dog
they'd be like hey that's Ralph that dog
bites you he's been a seven year vet no
I'm not gonna bite you good
they go
hey you killed our [ __ ] test dog I'm
like oh he was biting a bit on my arm he
told me he was good it's biting me
he served seven years a night gotta know
what to do with that [ __ ] in this
training lesson yeah
oh God's [ __ ] eyes out [ __ ] man run
him forward
I I don't like how you can pull my hips
in like that yeah although I've seen you
do that to heavyweight so I don't feel
as bad that was the thing yeah you get
your you got the good you got good pull
power good pull that's sucked in I'll
suck in you you pull a grown man out of
a well with no problems what's the most
you ever done this way
I don't know
I feel strong dude that dog gave some oh
the thing is I thought the thing is a
hood on
got a little hoodie here so I'll put
that on you look like you look you look
like the you look like you're doing
audition for the bad guy in the new Thor
movie
the god killer yeah look at how I'm
standing
my back straight Assassin's Creed rinks
Edition that was bad with my my neck
here it could have been nice Ramadan
could have been a Million Dollar Baby
Kiss situation oh I'm just saying I'm
just saying
yeah you're you're not a fun guy to
tussle with so you guys for Thanksgiving
you got the Christmas tree popping got
the Christmas tree yeah that's why I got
B I got we got thank everyone has
Thanksgiving on Thursday and Thursday is
also thick Thursday we're dropping the
new merch new I love those jerseys the
authentic MLB thick jerseys this one and
the military one with hoodies and hats a
lot of people on my shows yes sir that
drops thick Thursday but then on
Friday's Boston's birthday so you have
thick Thursday Thanksgiving Thursday and
then you have Boston's birthday on
Friday it's in it's daddy's not gonna
get any rest yeah that's what I'm trying
to tell you I want to start thin boy
I like that it's kind of good
we have the patent for that so don't try
to [ __ ] steal it we're already
[ __ ] copyright
I like to just see people every guy on
it now ah someone still do it people
suck
um yeah so Thursday family
Friday bossy's Birthday family and
friends yeah you just get no rest my
people at your house you know
I'd tell my girl like we got to whiten
it up man you're America man you ain't
having the pozole for Thanksgiving we're
waiting it off well yeah why not man my
kids are half white man yeah can't be
all Mexican all the time she bought him
the World Cup Mexico Jersey I'm like why
don't you give him a us or England
because that's that those Mexican Roots
Run Deep this is still in my English
Roots right so let's let's go and get
because and now Mexico and US suck at
sock but if you had a choice between
Denver and Mexico oh you go Denver right
no [ __ ] oh no no man Michael is like
Meg let's meet her and arguing about
this but but like Denver you know Aurora
outskirts you know what I mean like I'm
from Ohio we're known for Mass Shooters
okay you know what I mean go with them
when is the World Cup started already oh
wow yeah it started [ __ ] America in USA
was winning too
Now American women's soccer dominate
yeah like England hey Iran try this on
for size 16. now we tied whales 1-1
that's not good Qatar it's in Qatar and
they lost to Ecuador well qatar's a
[ __ ] nightmare right because they
made all these promises there's no more
there's no more corrupt group than the
World Cup and the money that they take
so right with Qatar they outbid uh it's
supposed to be in La supposed to be
America they outbid us so it went to
Qatar and then what they do when they do
in like States like or country like
Qatar they did this in Brazil so they
built these massive stadiums so the
whole world comes
and I think they said over a thousand
workers have died because it's like
slave labor yes these people die but
then after the World Cup leaves they
just leave those up yeah it ruins the
cities that's right and they ruin them
and then in Qatar remember too they're
like no we'll be cool to give me normal
stuff just like any World Cup
the day before the World Cup gets
announced
there's no alcohol there's no loud
sharing there's no talking to women do
you know this yeah there's no loud
cheering it's unbelievable who wants to
watch the World Cup that way get out of
your mind isn't it nuts dude and also
it's at 2AM [ __ ] off
now now time to if USA or England get
you know to like the semis they do well
I wake up for those games yeah I would I
just got my druid in the mail okay be
cool English Jersey oh yeah oh yeah I
love the World Cup I do too I love
guitar it's been a disaster dude we're
watching this video uh me and Delirious
are watching on uh in Qatar dudes doing
a live interview
the guitar security comes up to us you
have to shut this down you're too loud
because they want to suppress it they
want to shut everything down that's
right so like Budweiser and all the
alcohol they they it's you know for the
the big games they send all their
beverages they halted all that let me
ask you a question is that just eight
inches is is anti-alcohol such a bad
thing think about how much how many
problems said this before yeah in [ __ ]
yeah
but then uh how about like how far you
want to take it it's fast food a bad
thing yeah like the Obesity is the worst
problem that we have in America yeah
be an alcoholic didn't kill if you had
covet I've I've not been drinking lately
[ __ ] I know they come in you're like
oh my face looks cool and I my face is
so swollen I had three guesses the wine
last night and the thing of teeth I'm
like oh God that's not [ __ ] house oh
that's not dude my face still swollen I
just I thought red wine I know I still
have it I'm like okay my daughter goes
oh you drank and I go because because my
girl was feeding my baby uh goldfish why
are you giving them junk food we had
this little argument my daughter's like
you drink dad relax I go I don't drink
actually she goes you don't drink I go
no I don't drink she goes when was I say
I'm drinking I'm having a drink in a
week that's a week but I had to win
that's a lie also it's a lie so that
that we get home and what's the first
thing I do is I open it I crack open no
we went to eat lunch I have a beer then
I have another beer she goes oh really
think at home and I have wine
okay yeah well she goes cool that's
great I mean I started drinking on
Sundays because I'll go hard my liver
will literally hurt when I'm flying back
Sunday morning so I'll drink
you know probably two doubles three
doubles every show
you know Thursday Friday Saturday and
then Sunday you had I would I would you
know eat some greens do some liquid IV
and daddy gets his body right right yeah
it's Yellowstone season five I'm gonna
put my cowboy hat on drink some whiskey
with the boys by the boys I mean people
I've never met on TV yep hey B yeah
you're already taking break because
you're taxing but let's take a little
break from fighting the kid and check
out about God knows what his draftking
Sportsbook an official Sports brain
partner of the NFL is my go-to when I'm
betting on the NFL this holiday season
and right now new customers can bet just
five dollars on any NFL team to win
their game and get two whoa 150 in free
bets B you can just watch you can watch
sports and get 150 in pre-bets that's
right dude check this out right now
everyone can earn up to 100 boost with
DraftKings stepped up same game parlays
go to DraftKings sports book app play
same game parlay combine multiple bets
like with team will win player props
Point totals and more the more legs you
add the bigger to the Boost the bigger
shot to win big minimination eligibility
restrictions notes for details download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app right now
use code fighter place a five dollar bet
on any NFL team to win by the Cowboys
over the Giants I like the Packers
always play well unless it's Minnesota
Packers against the Eagles excuse me the
Packers over the Eagles calm down
I'm not saying that dude calm down the
bet on multiple teams do the parlay all
right and when you can basically fight
out five dollar bet on any NFL team to
win their game and get 150 in free bets
if they do only at draftking Sportsbook
with the code fighter minimum age
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details DraftKings my son will
do that with me my son is my son's
obsessed with [ __ ] uh booze and he'll
be like you guys want some cigars and
whiskey I'm like you're 11. what do you
know about that he goes just trying to
help out he goes then he goes like this
he goes for your wedding party I'd like
to uh I'd like to run the whiskey but
he's not drinking no he goes for your
wedding party I'd like to run the cigar
I'd like to be responsible for the
cigars and the whiskey I go that's not
happening he's so [ __ ] funny I'm
talking to Nick we're on the phone I'm
FaceTime and he goes hey Dad do you know
the dragon thing I go dragon and he goes
drag on these nuts across your face old
school old school drag on these nuts
I'll give them another one and he hung
up on me
[ __ ] you're 11 years old that's
so funny
oh [ __ ] yeah enjoy some whiskey dude
enjoy some whiskey I love it
yeah we can't send enough cases at the
shows this first thing that sells out
how crazy how much it's good whiskey
yeah people are buying it it's nice even
when they don't buy the merge because
Wisconsin people are cheap I love it
my skin in the wintertime whiskey oh
yeah I was walking down the beach
yesterday I saw an older gentleman older
gentleman clearly had money with this
golden retriever off leash just sitting
at his feet why does he have money what
do you think you have money because it
was in uh Manhattan Beach and he was a
Redondo or whatever and he was outside
this large 20 million dollar house on
the beach and he's just sitting there
with his hair back heater right probably
seven years old with his dog and he just
had a glass of whiskey looking at the
sunset and just kind of [ __ ] sipping
it and just kind of taking in I was like
that's that's living that's 70. your dog
whiskey
he had this insane like three-month-old
Dutch Shepherd that came from like it it
looks it's just a liability and he goes
like this he goes I go would that make a
good pedophile and train it to bite he
goes I mean it would make a terrible pet
because in two years he becomes if you
don't train that dog he's gonna bite
people uh with the the guy get my the
Cane Corso from he's where he's
FaceTiming show me all the dogs right
and then he the chemist grows back whoa
hold on back up back up what's that it's
some South African Bordeaux that's a
burble and it's adorable
he goes uh these can you know 180 some
or 200 pounds we go excuse me I think
sick that's exactly I knew he goes no no
no no you have kids right yeah you can't
have it no and he goes I just sold two
to Kevin Hart Kevin has kids you saw him
to him he goes
they Patrol his property on the outside
and he has a trainer like a like a
person with them 24 7 it's his security
yeah he's like they're not family dogs
he goes they can't come inside they're
not and he goes you basically have two
mountain lions patrolling your property
yeah why did those dogs are already I I
think you're better off having a dog
that looks scary and not a dog that's
gonna because those Malinois so the
reason they use the army use is almost
exclusively Malinois like the Seal Team
guys is they can pick that dog up yes
that's why they have those things on
them yeah they just pick it up and they
can they can grab it and put it you know
they parachute in with it go so fast
athletic smart [ __ ] it but the thing you
know I don't know a lot of the things
they need to exercise that's a working
dog that's like owning a Formula One car
it's not what you drive around I mean
you could get a Great Dane a black one
clip is theirs it kind of looks like
yeah
he said that dogs that though a dog like
kind of Corso or a dog like a [ __ ]
Malinois that dog is for the five
percent of Home Invaders who don't care
about dogs not afraid mm-hmm or
somebody's hopped up on [ __ ] and crazy
and that's why we do that's that's when
that dog is gonna go I'm gonna take the
fight to you holler yeah
it's not good otherwise
see ya I see Kanye uh uh I'm sorry
Connie so Kanye got reinstated on
Twitter he told him he's back with Elon
and how about Kanye's house off Malibu
off PCH you probably drive by coming
here I drove out all the time here's
Hanukkah oh he does things all over his
house happy Hanukkah and then he also
reinstated Trump yes and you see what I
do with Trump is brilliant we do with
Trump is he um he put up a poll put a
poll and there's like 52 yes then 40 no
but there's an influx on the nose so his
team goes that's interesting that's way
it doesn't work like that he looked into
his like millions and millions of bots
so now he can take that sample size of
all those Bots at the last of the woke
bot and get him out of there well you
know Sam bankman freed I don't know if
you followed this FTX thing oh Sam
tripley is bringing down for me the
green room he was the number two
biggest donor to democratic like he says
he gives to Republicans but there's a
catch to that let me explain something
to you first of all he gave to
Republicans that would have given him
favorable legislation sure but also when
you want your Democrat to win you you
you back the Republican who's most
likely to lose like you you find the
craziest Republican voters don't like
and you and you give them money and so
they beat the more reasonable oh
interesting yeah I didn't know that
about fundraising and about I know it
was shady yes baby yeah it's very smart
so uh but he he was President Biden's
number two donor everybody and the most
[ __ ] he just a corrupt crook you can
say whatever the [ __ ] you want he knew
exactly what he was doing by taking he
set up
um what's it called
um another company they were side by
side shared the same account yeah and
and one company ftt he had ftt tokens
Alliance Group The Alliance Group or
whatever and he took money from
depositors in in uh FTX and and brought
it over to the Alliance Group I think
it's called The Alliance what's it
called um
began trading and losing huge money
that's patently illegal now that's not a
regulated industry so you know but it's
all [ __ ] dishonest lost all that
money because all that money was on
paper you know what's interesting is uh
it's unbelievable yeah I mean it's nuts
he's worth 10.5 billion he has he's now
zero Alameda research Alameda I'm sorry
baby baby
I lost money though man
is he worth zero now because you think
you'd invest in other stuff well here's
the thing listen you don't what he did
was horrible you don't get that level
even though it's uh fraud and all that
stuff without realizing that this
thing's gonna end eventually so I would
assume he's investing other things I
guarantee he's not broke well it's like
when M.C hammer everyone's like he's
broke you know MC Hammer was not manager
for years we'd be on a plane like oh I
was MC Hammer bro yes I'm still flying
on private planes yeah um
yeah this is easy to hide crypto yeah
this this is here's the here's the catch
here's the catch there's about I guess
600 million or 6 billion something is
missing that was hacked into and it's
just gone hacked yeah now the question
is did he have a back door and did he
hack it and put it somewhere would
absolutely better
he's a smart kid I mean probably a
terrible person not that smart he just
got [ __ ] well no you're gonna get
you're not gonna nobody beats the
government never oh they have we haven't
heard so you can't be this much of a
[ __ ] crook
but it's amazing like it's amazing that
the that that he was giving to so many
of these well that's the that's the
Pablo Escobar thing and the El Chapo
they give back communities they go
through like favorable boxes they're
like Robin they're so great yeah they're
like uh yeah you know that's what they
do so then people like you know they're
actually nice guys like you know they're
doing that for a reason correct I think
I read this instrument I retweeted it
and I I forget who posted but they're
talk this guy who business guy and goes
hey not a fan of Elon but he goes what
he's doing with Twitter he's getting all
this backlash right now he goes this has
been done before and he goes I'm
surprised higher level people in
business aren't realizing this I forget
the exact term but what he's doing and
business do it all the time is when he
came in made those insane demands like
we're working 70 hours a week and he
gave him he gave them a project it was
like whoever can't do this well what
he's doing is I forget the term of it
but 90 of the work is done by like 10
employees and the other people are just
bullshitting freeloading elon's trying
to see who's going to stick through it
and stick and try and get this done it's
like Buds and other people yeah he's
trying to wean out the people that are
just freeloading yeah that's all he's
doing like can you believe he's doing
this there's a reason behind his Madness
he's doing it because and that's why
when people like you know uh someone
tweet out goes oh it's the end of
Twitter and Elon goes interesting we've
had the most usage and the most
followers we've ever had
well he's just trying all those media
he's trying to cut the fact all the
media writes this [ __ ] about well who
runs
[ __ ] the [ __ ] on the left so the
left uh constantly coming after him
because now they can't get away under
drugs when you talk this way people
think you're far right or they think
you're like some trumpist I'm not okay
I'm [ __ ] not I just don't think
there's anything if the right was doing
this I'd be good I don't think there's
any balance that's all yeah I know I
just call [ __ ] where [ __ ] is
done and when they're going after Elon
you're like can you read the you know
which my dad does he reads us so he's
like how about Elon I'm like how about
him yeah how about he's ruining Twitter
I'm like are you even on Twitter Dad no
he's like yeah he's running on me no
he's not ruining it no no no if you read
the the news yeah it seems like it's
this awful thing same thing will happen
with Rogan when he was going through his
thing you know people are talking about
have a rogue man screwed million new
subscribers yeah I was like no what no
do you do you even listen to show he's
not far right or none of us or far right
no it's in Far right how about how about
I'm in the vast middle yeah I'm not even
a trump fan how about that yeah [ __ ]
you know I wish Spotlight is like
Neo-Nazi that that's the appropriate
term well but I'm I'm
very liberal in a lot of ways I just
believe in my country and I'm a
patriotism I believe that there are
differences between men and women and
weird [ __ ] like that
I support military and police yeah that
makes me Far Right
Law and Order yeah in the military but
then also when it comes to abortion I'm
not right I'm no choice yeah me too but
also that's complicated too like I'm
religious so I'm I'm uneasy about it but
I'm definitely a pro-choice you're not
religious what's that someone to church
what
so when you're doing a headlock you know
when you're doing a headlock nice try
see how you skimmed over that what
yeah
I'm only really just what I need to be
yeah you know I'm afraid not to be
religious no me too I don't want to be
like [ __ ] God's like what's up now
you want to be my friend oh now you're
praying now you want to be my friend be
cool man yeah
trying to repent for my sins I have a
whole thing repent be cool be cool be
cool yeah but that's about your views
and I said your heterodox like both of
you are yeah on what yeah politically
yes
yeah without you on stuff you read the
you know the left is going after him
because they they can't get away with
the [ __ ] that they were doing you
know it's not the and then they're like
oh he's limiting freedom of speech and
it's like well who's suppressing speech
here yeah but also you know it there's
so much noise
on both sides
again it's like you know what I am I'm
probably Democrat heavy Republican light
I'm quoting my buddy David uh-huh like
that that's probably I'm I'm sorry
both sides have crazy people yeah
both sides are crazy I think Elon going
hard in the paint we've never seen it
before I was talking to Jay about this
when we're in Milwaukee because all the
news is getting announced about oh God
you think he reads it in this [ __ ] like
does he care and Chase like if you had
whatever he has 300 billion dollars goes
would you give a flying [ __ ] like new
but he probably loves proving that
naysayers wrong
you know he he yeah again too you got to
remember like um so my friend was just
one she just won city council and she
was uh in L.A and she's uh
she was fighting all these hardcore
leftists you know who have made La
amazing and uh and they were so nasty to
her they were calling her a far-right
trumpist and all that which none of that
is true she just believes in not having
homeless people and she her businesses
got destroyed during the BLM marches so
she just wants Law and Order she wants
just things like that but that's the
easy attack right that's the easy attack
kill oh whatever but they all go after
her then when she won now that she won
everybody everybody's texting her going
hey congratulations looking forward to
working together she's like you
[ __ ] you guys yeah I know
that's just politics kind of politics
that's it yeah it's just a dirty dude
now they need you yeah oh yeah now
you're in a position of power that's
with anything but you know it's not good
yep people suck man yep
let's see what we got
current events yeah already
not been going that long john
43 minutes
it's not too bad not too bad yeah
and plus it's it's a Thanksgiving week
so it is Thanksgiving
are we doing something on yeah we'll do
something on Wednesday
what will we do for Thanksgiving
well we did we did a holiday party once
right if you have a cat got all of it
what the cat like brought it all
remember well we'll see we're probably
not going to eat no I mean we actually
went to a restaurant you guys took us
out to go eat oh that's for Christmas
yeah for Christmas we'll do something
with the staff that'd be cool yeah we
did it last year oh we did well we did
in April for my special right except it
hits over a million I'll take everybody
out
boy some people man there it is I'll
take two Tomahawk steaks
the way it is let's go
ahead let's see what we got all right so
this happened uh last week I think it
was Jay Leno so apparently it was a fire
in his garage had to do with gas right
well he was working on like a 19 like
0-5 car something caught on fire and
caught his face and hands on fire yeah
so I when I first saw this I was like
okay a fire how bad could it be but
apparently he was pretty badly burned so
he was in there for like nine days and
you can see him
um well this is this is Tim Allen
actually talking about him after the
hyperbaric chamber in that other one
hold on this is the wrong video
here we go
so there's Tim Allen talking about Jay
Leno
that's Santa Claus dude car magazines we
did some jokes that's what we do we
commiserated we just connected his
friends
one thing you can do
space looks great it it didn't look all
that good to begin with so this is no
he's going with the George Clooney
though you're going to be surprised he's
handsome and he's happy and the
hospital's done a great job taking care
of thank you for your time Tim so this
is how this is a picture we saw of him
recently you see his neck face and his
arm here his hand he's like he was
legitimately wow look at his arm yeah
it's pretty bad yikes
yeah
yeah so it's a real still in the door no
[ __ ] joke dude can't stop won't stop
no Canadian tuxedo baby he's gonna be
all right but that's he's fine did you
go down chance see the old car he's
working on
I think they had a picture of the yeah
there you go yep that 1907 oh a steamer
apparently caught on fire
um
work on one of these vehicles in the
Burbank garage while trying to
unclog a fuel line on a 1907 White Steam
car he was sprayed with gasoline which
erupted into flames
his friend saved his life thank goodness
first friend Jesus Christ
it's no joke dude ah terrible
oh boy what else you got you all right
she's all right thank God yeah
um so I this was interesting to me so
Jennifer siebel Newson who is
gavinism's wife she had or ex-wife okay
yeah thank you so she testified for the
Harvey Weinstein trial and she said that
she had a fake an orgasm to get him to
finish early right so she can stop the
rape which oh damn to me even that it
sounds weird but
um so in court the prosecutor asks I
think it's a prosecutor asked her to
fake him yeah to do it again like can
you show me lots of prosecutors probably
Weinstein's defense
prosecutors wouldn't do it yeah the
defensive would do it but she was like
no I'm not doing that yeah but
apparently she talked about his weiner
too yeah
hold on California's first yes she's
still married to Newsome God damn how
far is first lady Baldwin defense
attorney Mark asked her how she
indicated her pleasure during an alleged
two on Five Minutes at The Pennsylvania
Hotel in Beverly Hills where she claims
Weinstein raped her
um this is not When Harry Met said I'm
not doing that good for her
um who referred to as of course Jane Doe
so this whole thing is kind of weird
though because it's supposed to be a
business meeting quickly turns something
else when Weinstein 100 understand what
he wrote then sort of manipulate and
threaten her Weinstein penetrate her
private parts with his fingers then his
deformed penis which you described a
kind of fish-like penis something was
distorted in the testicles lots of skin
lots of skin down there
weird God he's so disgusting so he she
got to a point where they're having sex
but then
you know I have look I don't know the
guy the guy is a rapist you know what
I'm saying like the guys are not buying
it no so no she so she even said like so
she sent emails after that rape like you
know thank you for so much for taking or
giving me
Oscars or whatever let me explain that I
know bro I know I get it no because my
so my my my girlfriend of many years
yeah was one of the first women to come
out against Harvey Weinstein I was super
powerful and she told me all these
stories
well the guy would come out he'd be
completely naked and he would chase you
around a [ __ ] thing and he would be
like I'm sorry let me just see your tit
let me just grab you and when you are
when you have this giant man in a
[ __ ] room and you don't know what to
do this pig who's got that much power
and he can ruin you which he did to Mira
Sorvino and a lot of other women
careers too yeah but a lot of them
didn't we don't hear about it ever again
they never worked again
and this guy does that and you don't
know if he's you don't know he's crazy
he might kill you you know that's
they're they all these women have the
same story of like just freezing and not
knowing what the [ __ ] to do which I
understand yeah he is a piece of [ __ ]
that needs to be you know [ __ ]
somebody needs to take a bat to his
[ __ ] head no he's definitely a piece
of [ __ ] I get that but I think some okay
so even with this girl uh Newsome's wife
she said that she was hustling to get
something from him as well that's true I
think a lot of times the girls will get
into a situation even if it sounds
[ __ ] up
but it they might know they're getting
into a situation no no they give them
something they give they get definitely
but okay but so so so all men if I'm
meeting with Harvey Weinstein as a man
I'm there for a reason yeah okay but
hold on so so women so if you're an
actress or whatever the way he would do
it I'm telling you it's no he's trying
to [ __ ] he'd charm you and he'd be like
you I want you in one of my movies let's
have a meeting and you go to meet him in
a hotel but all of a sudden why are you
going to a hotel the woman a woman would
come out and say he wants to meet you
he's one of his assistants was a woman
would say he wants to meet you in his in
his room so now you're like oh they
thought they were going to Hotel like
Beverly Hills though to have like a nice
lunch and they'd be like actually he
changed the mean to his Penthouse
I'm on your side but I'm saying oh okay
so wait let's listen so then you're a
woman you're this happened to my friend
you're trying to make it as an actress
which is impossible yeah the most
powerful man in Hollywood can make your
career he tells you are amazing and
everything else now he's naked
my ex-girlfriend tried to leave he
blocked the door you gotta here to I
know I know tells the tale of he has a
car service come get her brings her to a
house which is an hour away a thousand
I've been treating everybody's like he
he orchestrates it so you actually if
she were to run out she'd just be like
and 90 minutes from Manhattan also back
then the guy could you know as an
actress your career is over yes so
that's the big thing but and also it's
happening so fast and he's being
physical and he's on top of you and
you're like what the [ __ ] any and he
surprises you he came out of the
bathroom on my girlfriend naked
[ __ ] naked in his house there were
pictures of his kids and his wife
and he was up there and he because he
wanted he goes I want you to read the
script I want to show I want to give you
the script yeah he invited her out to a
Premiere it wasn't a Premiere it was a
movie they were together
Newsome's wife also uh Sabel Newsome
also sent dozen of emails after the
ledge rape including emails soliciting
support for Gavin newsom's mayor
campaign in San Francisco so it's like
okay it's an exchange of it's [ __ ] up
but it's an exchange of [ __ ] like you
you go there you okay by the way in
Hollywood
you you know Hollywood people they must
know a little bit about Harvard
Weinstein no they did by that time those
women did not know that I'm telling you
they didn't okay
I knew
Einstein because of my friend I knew he
was a scumbag and when you worked with
him I also had friends who I remember
I'll quote my friends they were working
on a movie with him and I said how's it
going with that Weinstein thing and he
goes they go he's just a liar he's a
[ __ ] liar yeah okay I also know
people that that work with Harvey
Weinstein who are guys in a very
positive way remember he produced all of
Quentin Tarantino's movies and
everything else Quentin Tarantino said
this on Rogan he goes because Rogan
brought it up he goes did you know like
he was we like I knew he's always
aggressive with girls like there'd be a
girl in the room and like go Harvey
doing what Harvey does we'd like you
know hit on him and do his things he's
like I wish I would have said something
yeah but a lot of all of us everybody
thought he was just kind of gross and he
was just hitting him which he is nobody
knew that the people in Hollywood I'm
sorry the good women didn't say anything
because they were [ __ ] terrified and
so what happened I understand but but
see whenever you're questioning this you
have to understand and this is I'm
emotional about it because you know what
happens you have relationships but but
there's a guy who's who's well who I'm
so I'm I'm I'm sticking up for these
women here because they're all telling
the same story
there is no doubt he's a rapist piece of
[ __ ] yeah there's no doubt he did all
these things and back then to your
defense back then too there wasn't a lot
of course of action you couldn't do [ __ ]
Mira Sorvino she got she won an Oscar he
shut her career down she never worked
but I see what you're saying they're
doing because because this is weird too
uh because says in one of the emails did
in March 2nd 2007 about 18 months after
alleged rape uh Newsome wrote thank you
to Weinstein for including her and two
others on an Oscar party guest list she
put we had such a fun time and then read
this right here it says one question why
should we continue to correspond with a
man who brutally raped her she said I
was just hustling so hustling I think a
lot of times not all the time but a lot
of times if you're going to get yourself
in a situation where you know someone's
like in a power powerful position you
might just have an exchange of like all
right I'll give you this give me this
you know I mean not not rape no no
you have no idea what happened also not
sex so the good thing about as a guy who
[ __ ] who got a paid you know who I
mean who who
you know with one of the paid a price
for this [ __ ] I didn't do anything yeah
I'm saying so I'm I'm so I'm defending
I'm gonna defend me two for a second
the fact of the matter is before me too
in this [ __ ] town
man ran the whole business they could
get away with whatever the [ __ ] they
wanted especially if they were powerful
and they did not most men but a lot of
men scumbags and the fact of the matter
is if you wanted to work as an actress
and we can go all the way back to
Marilyn Monroe's [ __ ] biography
autobiography you had to play the game
which means you had to suck somebody's
dick who you didn't like and that was
the way it was done and the the one
thing that you can the good thing there
are bad things about me too because they
it took a lot of people down didn't
deserve it but it also the good thing is
that it created a sense of fair play and
it created a woman a female whisper
Network that never existed before so
that scumbags like that [ __ ]
can't get away with it which is great
back then they ruled everything and you
had to do anything they said and they
could rape you or do whatever they
wanted or even get out get away with
other stuff it says here it just says
when asked you tried to say no to uh
Harvey Weinstein Nissan said I did with
my voice and with my body I did by
slamming my legs together I tried to get
out of there I tried so hard keep going
down God he is terrible looking uh she
was accused from the stand she was
crying so in this article it says also
when when she was you know asked like
why would why would you
send emails to this guy who really raped
you and she just you know started crying
and doing this here's what I'm saying
like I don't
it's a tough Hill to die no so what I'm
saying with this is
there's definitely girls out there that
are getting they want to get something
for something and they'll trade sex for
that it's just reality right it's just
reality in Hollywood it's really so I
think when stuff like this happens later
on there's men too that yeah dude I
haven't had women yeah I'm saying that
it's real it's not it's not a fake thing
no it happens so when I see stuff like
this especially with this kind of thing
but I would say the difference is the
thing is a voluntary Arrangement right
so in Hollywood there's always been sex
for sale and that's a voluntary
Arrangement and if you want to get into
that as a consenting adult that's your
business that's fine the line is when
that's the last thing on your mind and
you're trying to have a career and this
piece is [ __ ] gets you in a room and
[ __ ] I think I don't know we all know
that what was I think what Chin's trying
to say is they're they're she says she's
hustling there's been some times where
she's hustling Weinstein's husbands yeah
and I'm
not advocating this I'm I'm thinking
it's [ __ ] up but it happened took a
bunch of swings and I would assume hit a
lot of home runs with this Behavior
didn't get in trouble and he hooked them
up with you know goals and stuff so I
mean some some of these girls I'm not
saying all of them but some of them know
what they're getting into which I think
is something we should actually expand
in any way no no we're defending I'm not
saying like people are not I'm saying
that I'm assuming that's Chin's
perspective yeah some girls know what
they're getting if I do this for you
you're gonna do this yeah yeah and then
later on they'll switch it around and
say like oh it was rape well that's
always been the case in Hollywood yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah that's not
the case with Harvey Weinstein no he's a
piece of obviously he's a piece of [ __ ]
also it would matter if you knew that
going into the meeting because if it is
surprised upon you you know I'm sure he
surprised all those girls though well
that that is different than going when I
wake up with Harvey Weinstein I know I'm
gonna he's gonna force me to have sex
but I'm gonna
decide to do it before I leave my hand
he's the worst guy in the world but chin
saying that there is some exchange of if
I do this for you you're into she says
but here's the other thing with Harvey
like you're saying you're a woman and
you know if you don't your career is
over that's true that's just that's
awesome I would [ __ ] him you know young
man
because you'd be scared to not have a
career afterwards right now be the next
Batman but I'm saying that that's the
real thing but I mean I would have to if
you said Brian you gotta you gotta take
it in the ass or you're never gonna work
again you'll never have a job
on the wall and [ __ ] go to my happy
place and even have 39 if we're not
filming it yeah you know what I'm saying
though it's like like this guy that that
guy that guy that's what they mean by
using your power using your power to get
sex but right what's tricky is when they
say it's rape later and when they say
it's rape later okay that's why a very
different case yeah but I don't like
that part well nobody does [ __ ]
especially me and and sure you don't
like that she said I'm hustling
that's what that trigger that maybe she
went oh yeah there's something going on
there's something around me for money
afterwards doesn't negate the fact that
a crime happened yeah that's right like
you know if your boss raped you and you
went into work the next day because you
needed them if it's rape would you go to
work the next day and acted it nicely
but if it's raped if it's rape like if
someone like forcibly raped you this is
all this is all these are all the things
that are that are presented you know you
know what you know what I'm interested
like where was she at in her career back
then yeah like her family she was an
actress like you know she's doing well I
don't know yeah I never heard of her
about her before this no I I had no idea
it doesn't matter he's a scumbag oh no
what I'm saying my main thing is like
okay to say it's rape after you're
saying you're hustling and you're you
you know like you went to the hotel you
you pretended to finish your orgasm look
what
she stands nothing again from standing
up there on on that on that you know
other than you know what she got boned
by Harvey Weinstein which is
embarrassing and then now she's gonna be
like oh you know I was I didn't want to
do it he did it to me that kind of thing
I'm being real here I'm just being
honest man
I got no I have no time for your
argument but but Chen would it I I no no
he he might have but I'm saying this to
him let's see if he did let's say let's
say let's say I was a female right yeah
I had a audition after the show today
right and I tell you guys I'm like I've
heard he sleeps with him and the women
sleepers they give him the part so and
you guys go are you gonna do them like
I'll see how it goes maybe and I have
that in my you know I'm like I give him
whatever I suck him off he gives me a
gig in a big movie and then I get there
I'm like oh I can't do this and then he
rapes me if he rapes you though and
that's what he did chin don't defend
Harvard I'm not defending anything I
told you don't call questions I told you
he's a piece of [ __ ] don't stop with
this argument stop I understand what
you're saying General don't use him as
an example Maybe thing in general okay
Brian she's hustling what is that what
the [ __ ] is that yeah chin doesn't like
that
doesn't mean hustling doesn't mean you
get to get raped surprised what is
hustling everybody hustles in Hollywood
I hustle by the way is that woman right
sex is hustling too okay it's hustling
if I want to [ __ ] do something like
if I have if I'm in a powerful position
I want to have sex with this girl she
wants uh she wants to get a job with me
right that's that's fine that's hustling
but that's fine but no so that's she's
saying it's rape now let me tell you
what stopped ever since me too she
didn't say let me tell you what stopped
ever since me too those questions now
and it's a good thing now guys know if
they're gonna mix sex with [ __ ] work
you you are you are available and that
by the way and I got a 14 year old
daughter that's a good thing as one of
the bodies on the side of the road with
this [ __ ] me too
that [ __ ] is good so the overall thing
is good because now you have all the
[ __ ] like that who are in positions
of power who would bully or make women
[ __ ] them to get a job or whatever uh
suck my dick and I want what I'm saying
all that [ __ ] that now women can hustle
like the way men can hustle yeah with
their work and their energy and they can
go hey and and now what happens is when
you remove the the liability of sex from
the the room now you got now the world's
a better place now exactly so Brad what
I'm saying though is some girls know
what they're getting into no doubt right
so that's all I'm saying and when I see
stuff like this happening later she says
I was hustling this and that whatever
and she's thinking come on SO Chin's
talking about in just a you're using it
in general no no this is not saying I'm
looking at this article he doesn't like
that and they said well why she's
working she's emailing later and she
goes wow it's hustling oh thank you so
much for the tickets
because chin the alternative is is total
eradication because the the alternative
is is essentially career death and your
whole life so as a woman she goes I
gotta suck this up this is the worst
experience I gotta suck it up because
I'm trying to make a living because my
dreams which I agree with you so then
she goes yes I sent an email after that
yes I had to put all push all this [ __ ]
down because uh the the the alternative
was Annihilation okay so Bart do we
agree though that some girls know what
they're getting into nobody ever talked
about totally separate no no but we're
not talking about rape you're saying I'm
talking about exchange yeah exchange so
some girls do they do that's not a
that's we know girls that do that but
this isn't a wine scene thing though
chin I think that's where you're off on
that no I'm not saying okay I'm just
saying this particular article made me
it just had lots this article and yeah
and take this I'll see what you're
saying yeah I mean gun to your head and
somebody goes give me your uh give me
your watch or I'm gonna kill you and
then later somebody goes what is
happening because I'm surviving and then
you report it to the police they
wouldn't be like wait you said you were
surviving back then but now you're
saying it's like well I technically had
an option but the option was if I get
robbed by gunpoint I'm calling the
police right away that's what I would do
I'm not gonna wait 20 years later very
very different no he's bringing up bad
examples
right like I get it and I understand
what you're saying and believe me and
and yes in my case yeah
not so like in this non-harvey
Weinstein's case but there's there's
cases where it was the cool thing to do
to bring men down yeah without any
Exposition
[ __ ] that me too movement swayed so
far over here
and it's embarrassing to see to be
connected to be having sex with Harvey
Weinstein it's embarrassing especially
why the [ __ ] would you want to admit
that to anyone yeah you know like who's
gonna get out yeah
revolutions always swing all the way
over no it is it's horrible to be raped
of course it's uh shameful and
embarrassing so it might not be the
thing unless you are really eager to
identify as as a victim and get
attention that way it you know tends to
not be something that like all right
we've talked about all right whatever
let's get into some some I don't know
what else uh okay so Dwight Howard
played in Taiwan recently I don't know
what's going on so he's he's not within
uh he's playing over there yeah so
apparently he just destroyed like
destroyed he did like he had like ten
three-pointers yeah he's shooting like a
bunch of Threes at like 50 points I mean
40 rebounds a true that's another 38
points 25 rebounds oh such a freak
physical freak such a freak and he was
the guy that uh Kobe would Punk because
he's so soft
he'd mess with him yeah because you hate
how soft he was yeah Cody was like you
know what I would do if I had your size
and straight like his shoulders were
nuts yeah he's gay right
oh there was a there was a rumors right
like I don't care with uh it was with
trans something yeah something like that
um
it's on sport too dude this kid is a
stud that is a very muscular young man
in
if you go woke I will stop it that's a
very it's a fat kid he's very very true
yeah that's a very strong it is what it
is that's an obese child uh who's very
athletic let's go ahead though and lose
some weight and be the best we can be
but very athletic but also just keep
doing what you're doing dude yeah stay
thick and do backflips yeah wait let's
go to Mark's right now hold on thick
flips yeah I think it was wait I want to
see that charging canine okay so when I
saw okay by the way we we talked about
this on a shop show but uh the Power
Ranger the Green Power Ranger who's very
popular one of the more popular ones in
the Power Rangers series my favorite
personally he was also an MMA fighter he
fought MMA undefeated 5-0 is that true
no so he unfortunately committed
suicides 49 years old
yeah no idea why but
bummer man yeah that is a bummer but he
was an MMA fighter too yeah
hmm oh by the way that's a baby yak that
thing is cute baby yeah [ __ ] I'll
squeeze that I'll kiss that thing right
on the nose oh my god dude you get me
with that baby yak and my baby Boston oh
yeah shut down I want to see the the uh
oh sorry here we go so this I don't know
the video is not that great though I'll
tell you if it's real so the Apparently
this kid's dog saved this kid from
another dog that ran away yeah the dog
was he gonna attack him yeah I was about
to see so right now this dog this is
about to attack the kid oh my God and
this dog fights it
oh two dogs yeah oh [ __ ] oh wow
wow
oh I I think that dog was just running
over to play see my dog that dog was
running over to play with uh
that I was running over to play with the
kid
I mean with that with that with the
other dog that's what he's doing watch
this let's see you can tell uh
uh it's tough to tell
and they went back for it I don't know
I don't know that's pretty sweet yeah
yeah cause you got it okay so the
neighbors all got loose from the
backyard whatever Jesus Christ man but
that's the beauty of dogs too they
they're awesome and that was that was a
German Shepherd that did that that's
pretty cool protecting his uh his pack
oh yeah oh sweet oh yeah six-year-old
boy Jesus Christ
all right Marcus
oh I posted this this [ __ ] boom Oh
look at the dudes look at the hit look
at this cell phone
[Music]
ouch that was at the UCLA USC game USC's
for real kid decided California
football's back yes La is good USC's
really good if they went out they might
get in the top four there's a guy in
Hawaii or maybe it was in Small he was
uh this kind of guy like that it was
running and you watch these two Samoan
dudes who were giants exactly but they
were so much faster
they just [ __ ] ran them down I was
like the ones are the [ __ ] they're
a woman right like this one's that
octopus punch fish for no reason that's
hilarious that's good it looks at
Photoshop but
boom
now usually they just eat them right
they just he doesn't I guess
I was probably trying to grab him wasn't
he I mean hey look I'm just saying what
the scientists say but they're saying
apparently he whipped punched them
randomly for no reason even looking I
was like oh it says it's because fish
attract predators and he isn't trying to
get eaten so he doesn't want to fish
near him because fish will bring in a
predator bring a shark find your own
hind spots they're not just the bullies
of the sea
which one do you guys want
ah give us give us the woman arrested
scientists discover ideal hangover cure
woman arrest us after smuggling 450 000
worth of cocaine in her wheelchair at
JFK airport now those would be tired
from a car though right yeah that's not
a wheelchair wheelchairs going on there
I wonder why they'd show pictures of a
car without a wheelchair yeah they're
looking for that low budget that's a
good question maybe that was the
wheelchair wait a second yeah it's about
a monster truck yeah do I have a monster
why have an F-150 in here a deal here
lime acronym study publishing Journal
research the mix is even more efficient
with supplement by a plate of cheese
with tomato and cucumber also I'm trying
to [ __ ] my pants try it out next week
Brendan
coconut water pear and lime and a plate
of cheese oh the pear makes up most of
the drink at 65 it's a lot of pair
followed by a sweet lime never met a
sweet lime and then also coconut water I
know the coconut water is good because
the electrolytes you know when you go to
the hospital in Brazil the IV is coconut
water really
all the electrolytes yeah is that the
saline solution
woman discovered discovers husband
yeah that's pretty crazy 14 years spying
on her 16 year old take a shower look at
this she finds the device in the shower
oh no oh no
now see the dad is the is it the stepdad
I assume yes you would assume it's a
stepdad
yeah because the daughter's 16 years old
for a previous marriage
what a creep
oh my God
Oh my Jesus Christ
oh my God that is such a heart she's
shaking yeah she's like you scumbag leg
it looks like he had a perennial nerve
issue potentially that's the only
explanation I could think of and he's
trying to like shake it out during the
fight oh man that looks ridiculous no
never
you're just trying to get it going there
Jesus Christ that's happened a lot these
days huh yeah
your perennial nerve motion the rest of
your saved man who got himself stuck 12
meters down a sewer pipe
there's like 40 feet down a pipe
I don't know how we got
you know he's in oh [ __ ] what oh and his
arms like this yeah oh I bet his arm's
gonna sleep that's so terrifying how the
[ __ ] did they find him was he trying to
mention the release I think he was like
help I'm down in the pipe
but why is he in a pipe why are you in a
sewage pipe bro a few questions hey why
how'd you get down there b how'd they
even know he's in there yeah that is
trying to evade the draft in Russia just
from a page called look at this Russian
which is one of my favorite Pages oh my
God
oh this is gone wait wait which one is
that that's the second to last uh what
language sounds like to people who don't
speak the language oh damn it wait okay
actually go to the next one I can bring
up uh because I post that through
Brennan's Facebook the other day Alex
Bahia when he sees that Izzy has boob
has a boob so this is a meme format that
I think is hilarious where it's like
he's just mimicking everything as he
does like as he takes up Golf and then
it's like Alex bahara on the on the golf
course
is your uh is your money on the fact
that bahara loses his crowns very
quickly
depends whether I mean it's all up to
predicate off the UFC you know if they
give them who are they who are the
wrestlers that can do that to him I mean
you look at the top 10 guys give me a
problem Whitaker I think would be a
problem for him but Tori can wrestle uh
Brunson is he able to neutralize the
wrestling by staying on his feet no
those guys would get him down really and
then you see his grappling I mean he is
he got him down yeah so you look at
Robert whittaken rest his ass off gear
can there can wrestle uh vittori brings
pressure dick Brunson You Know Jack of
my answer wouldn't be a problem uh my
one the fight I want to see is Alex
Pierre and uh Darren till
that'd be fun oh really yeah it'd be a
great fight I think Till's a little
small
yeah
his nickname's the gorilla he's a big
boy he's a big boy
he's big no punk either
he's a fight uh two weeks what's his
ranking what's Till's ranking he's nine
he hasn't fought in a while he got hurt
you think so yeah why no no wrestling no
grappling I feel like uh Pierre is a
higher level Striker I'm just saying as
far as uh stylistically because he would
um
you know
you get a kickboxing match yeah this one
yeah
I had a squirrel trying to play
basketball did a serious shadow
's trying to play ball
oh oh
why is that squirrel just chilling baby
no it's crazy it's a baby squirrel hell
no that boy
that boy ass squirrel I like your
Chipmunks squirrel
oh damn he's really trying I said yeah
that's a baby squirrel
so ridiculous Chipmunks
you can pick him up you pick up the baby
squirrel is a baby a baby squirrel and a
sugar glider different things right
I don't know let's go back here
I know I gotta pee one more one more I
want to show you guys I think I think
you'll like this too
um keep going keep going keep going
you'll see an Asian gentleman keep going
keep going keep going
two more
there we go
Ike for people who don't speak them
foreign
foreign
I mean a while ago
years ago guys I hope you enjoyed this
burnt orange experience I'm glad you're
bringing some color into your life with
the sand yes buddy I'm bringing some
color you bring some color you got a
bunch more tour dates on Naples off the
hook Florida Naples December one two
three and four
I got Boston Massachusetts last Boston
you're doing New Year's in Boston
because the 31st yeah I got New Year's
Live Boston I got Fort Wayne Indiana
Summit Comedy Club January 12 13 14. I
got zany's Nashville March I'm taking
all February off I think March 2 3 and 4
Zanies I got New York New York Sony Hall
March 11th that's one show maybe two I'm
not sure get your tickets at Tony Hall
it's gonna be good
uh I have one date we're rescheduling DC
kids we're rescheduling DC to early next
year so I end the oh he thick tour
December 1st through the 3rd that's
Providence Rhode Island The Comedy
connection those those are shows are
almost sold out so we might add some
shows but your boys fly into Boston then
driving to Providence Rhode Island
that's December 1st through the 3rd uh
next year we had some dates uh we'll
start filling it up but you have Naples
coming up in February you got Oklahoma
City Tacoma Washington Spokane but we
have the big uh kab ass fight pain with
the collab with bar stool for rough and
rowdy December 9th with Joey Diaz Dio
Vaughn and Rampage Jackson
I will be on thick boy YouTube uh that's
a Friday December 9th December 10th
we're doing UFC 282 uh Cal bass fight
campaign with Brian Callan Sam tripley
and a very special guest that's all on
thick boy so uh thick Thursday new merch
drops the official uh MLB thick boy
jerseys drop Thursday at 6 a.m Pacific
time so you have this brown juicy me
rocking now we have the military uh San
Diego Padres one uh dropping as well
Thursday you have the matching hats and
hoodies dropping as well then doing a
huge discount on all remaining inventory
so make sure you head over to
thickboy.com this thick Thursday and
then uh yeah then tiger thick whiskey
they're taking five dollars off uh
shipping and that's just you don't have
to have a promo code or anything you
just go to thickboy.com click on uh
tiger thick whiskey my boys that bourbon
Outfitter uh shipping that straight to
your house so even if we're not
Distributing in your state you can get
delivered to your door tiger thick
whiskey award-winning best gift of all
time five dollars off shipping only
that's thickboy.com for all that thick
uh thick Thursday starts 6 a.m Pacific
time all right that's it kids Brian want
to go take a [ __ ]
um that's it love you guys till next
time we're out